five four three two one zero
yeah I do like bughouse by I don't
usually play online I'll play over the
board if there's some opportunity okay
let's play let's play a walrus I'm gonna
play the a walrus in a while this is not
a good opening kids if you're watching
go to sleep also close your eyes also
don't try this at home
actually this is beginning to look fun
I'll put the bishop here I think there's
some compensation I guess md5 looming I
wanna play h4 Oh white plays h4 I mean I
could play d5 I mean I got five these
squares look tender some idea of Queen
e7 I don't know if I'm getting much I'm
trying some idea of this - hmm
there's some bishop move coming I'm
gonna double think lol I think this
makes more sense if visually g5 I might
have to play f6 185's coming that's kind
of scary
it's hard to deal with - I could take
but I might have to take oh and the
night takes fall yeah white sweating
some good news
know what to do
this is not an easy position because the
problem is 95s coming and the
combination of Bishop g5 9 697 it's
really hard threat to stop my knight
spins look thanks for subbing
masterminds I can't even play this
because Bishop here if I play Queen g8 I
guess Queen the AIDS or maybe I'll play
f6 I don't know
click Wendy it first it's such a sad
move ideas after this I played f6 to
stop a ship g5 Bishop f4 I'll play d6
and like barely survived oh that doesn't
even survive though I'm just in huge
trouble here
hmm
wondering if I can just castle
I'm gonna try that there's now a fishery
bg5 I have have six and one of the
points after Bishop f4 this my Kings not
on he ate so there's no like Knight f6
takes and double attack so I think I'm
okay here
even though I'm still much worse I'm
drinking I'm like some fruits herbal tea
and I have to sack the exchange some d5
idea there c6 - I mean a3 is expected
there should be six
just gonna lose the exchange
we're not dead yet it's actually good
like when you're down the exchange you
want ox of Claire Bishop's give you kind
of some hope to fight back I think all
the light squares are potentially in my
control I'll play 94 and 96 kind of
hangs I defend the night if castling I
have this move
I'm also sneakily attacking the rook
which I'm hoping my opponent yeah my
opponent misses because I played c5 it
looks like I was just defending the
Knights but the diagonal opened up
that's why you always have to see the
whole board I win both rooks now that's
so great yeah don't mess with the walrus
the dirty game White has one legal move
but probably just trying to control the
totes no I'm okay like just taking a
break letting the German settle down I
cry like a Grand Master yeah I mean
saltiness is I think a normal reaction a
few weeks ago I went to the Dead Sea
I've never seen anything so salty
because the like when you go in you just
start floating it's so salty it's like
40 percent salt
you have to be careful that like it
doesn't get in your eyes or your mouth
okay so just killing some time here well
um yeah we'll probably end up taking
something of some sorts why it might
actually take the pawn try and
destabilize my night's clean victory
yeah okay
save time that was nice yeah kudos to
leech us for having that so that option
it's also it's it's so nice that like
they allow you to claim the draw to if
you feel bad
I don't feel bad how do you become a GM
you have to work really hard play a lot
of tournaments and beets meet other good
players consistently why do you think
most top chess players have unstable
tempers I don't think that's the case
most a lot of top chess players like are
very just neutral but maybe you're just
thinking of a few people that represent
the overall population of top chess
players okay so we have symmetry okay
night here is a move if Bishop h4
there's a really cool move for black
yeah this is on this is stock fishes
novelty I discovered this a couple years
ago and this is one of the top computer
moves ideas simply f6 and drop the
bishop
unlike the previous game this opening is
actually sound like this is just a best
approach and so far I mean it's
basically computer preparation so now
the idea is g5 and if takes takes the
knight moves I trap the Michelle if h4 I
just take and play g4 White's kingside
structure is in shambles and the Knights
gonna have to go to a sad place maybe c5
yeah because I have the ID of the bishop
pair I want to open position and G's the
Jeep on is kind of a weakness so there's
some idea of Queen c7 and attack the G
pollen guess who's in first after two
games
oh it's diamond cuts good job diamond
cuts also can i play this move play this
move hitting the pawn I'm threatening
mean in one I'm also threatening this
pawn hopefully my opponent plays before
and just ends a pain yeah so the goal is
to catch up to diamond cuts Wow opponent
lets me even the poem and this move is
coming it's made I'd like to III Queen
Daisy three mates unexpected me haste
this game is gonna be a miniature yeah I
caught up the diamond cut let's go those
12 moves wait where am i I catch up oh
there I am I'm in first place he's
playing and dude something something oh
let's play E for I'm gonna continue
being aggressive so far the openings
have paid off I'm gonna play a hillbilly
attack I first saw this years ago
Carlson was playing it and having like
decent success you just want to meet the
opponent or just went out seven
g6 I think is the most popular move an
idea is not necessarily to win back the
pawn it's more to play f3 and then get
some get some compensation
so it's again it's I'm gonna play d3
probably hmm
let's play d3 and some idea of I'm just
attacking wow so black is castling into
the tack I'll start with this I could
even just Castle kingside
and get the roof data I file team should
be safe on g1 that's a decent move it's
like casting first I have a lot of
potential to attack I'll play Knight g5
so now basically the knight is tied down
to defending h7 oh also good morning to
Thomas Thomas was here earlier so I
assume you slept and then you woke up
shoutout to Thomas welcome back oh wait
one too many A's ok so I lost my bishop
that was actually one attacker but I
still have a lot of things on the
kingside very soon I'll need to
calculate there's one check the rook
here first
thinking about g4 at some point it could
be interesting the problem is the stuff
maybe King h1 I think I'm still down
upon but there's so much pressure and
black
I'm thinking 94 if we trade then I'll
have rook takes our six possibilities
also just want to take no I don't want
to relieve the tension too soon okay I
officially have all my pieces on the
kingside I think that's a good sign
I'm trying to remove a defender
basically the key defender
if takes takes I'll be threatening this
be threatening this this looks nice oh
it's 7 a.m. in Norway
it's 12:30 nan and st. Louis
so it's officially Thursday but it might
not be Thursday for the people watching
in the future a shout-out to those
people I guess there's a one in seven
chance that's Thursday for people
watching in the future ok so yeah that's
a move thinking G for now oh except the
bishops bishops no hunger defended so I
should take and then G for I mean each
six might happen it's getting messy at
the very least I'll win back upon I
think at the very most
maybe I'm meeting or maybe I wouldn't
apiece maybe I have actually have night
h3 it's an interesting or treating move
but the ideas after in that have 6 IV 5
there's Queen d5 check
I complain that f3 but that walks into
metaphor okay let's think I left three
nineth for the nice XIV five so this
this there's g5 there's e5 even I'm not
sure if I take this way takes
oh there's h6 first and then takes let's
do that because I was scared at first I
just saw this slide queen x g5 work h8
which is also interesting because I do
have a 5 but let's say h6 first the
intermezzo or Lord chunga's taking off
goodbye to the Lord
let's take
you just move back McQueen's gonna plant
itself on a good square I'll move back
this way keeping up on defended Queen d4
hmm yeah the problem is if we trade
Queens I'm gonna lose the pond then
they'll just be down upon so I guess I
don't want to trade Queens I don't
really want to do anything else takes
air takes this is a difficult position
Queen uh four
I don't know what to do here okay I'm
gonna play a very risky move basically
Gama ting some more pawns because
eventually I want to play this and sac
and meet somehow it's probably not
working starting with this move yeah
Queenie five good move I probably have
to take Oh remind me later yeah I'm
gonna be down like so many pawns I lose
this pawn I'm down two pawns
I I need a miracle to win this anything
this pawn I just want to activate the
rook found three pawns here and I'm down
like thirty seconds to draw thanks for
the bits let's go Jim I'm trying I'm
trying it's not easy being down Soni
pause
okay now I can activate that's a small
success it was a rock can do stuff from
behind she's on passant bees I'm a
passed pawn now that doesn't last
okay but I get the rook to be six and
then T cells ooh let's take first I'll
see four I see four as a bad move okay
defend the pawn on time that's nice
ya dirty flagging coming
let's take their sorry opponents you
played so well I'm not quick enough
yeah well thinking so I survived long
enough it's down three pawns for like
the whole engine yeah my tack didn't
work black played well to kind of
neutralized I I went a little bit too
crazy probably
my queen move the dirty flag yeah
but staying clean at least in terms of
points another caro-kann let's play
something new let's play um whatever
this is
Oh II 525 the move okay we're having um
will have a Marathi mind that's a
pleasant opening
I'm very easy to develop and just
control the center
yeah b5 is a move I think I can just
kind of ignore it b5 I play a three
preventing d4
and keep developing like Queen c2 rook
d1 I think is a the completed seven I
don't want to do too much with attention
and try and confuse black I'm realizing
I may have no if I plundered may have
given box some opportunity here that's
more worried about takes in c5 Bishop d3
is a move and d5 some of them I think d5
makes some sense try and close things
down grab space yeah cuz now these pawns
make the bishops and there's my c5
there's that move - don't play queen bee
one I want the rook to be on see you
want hmm
actually I don't know if I feel direct
to be unseen one let's start doing
maneuvering things like Knight g4 a3
idea to improve the bishop - maybe the
Bishop B belongs in c2 all blacks Bishop
is coming in I have to allow it
that's an okay trade for me so I want to
get the Knight to f5
and then jisuk could maybe weaken the
darks where's also take with a pawn here
open the file yeah let's let's just
control the file I'll play griff d2 just
preparing the double-up these are gonna
be the major targets we could even play
rook f3
maybe my knight should have come on
first it was a big opportunity
I'm just envisioning the the triple
battery I've not won
I mean 92 what to do I'll play 92 scurvy
you're learning from the legends I can't
can't blame you thanks for the bits
kriby
what to do here because Mike G fives
coming
yeah these pieces I don't know what
these pieces are doing but my knight
wants to come here to attack the pawn
it's a it's very nice position but it
takes a little bit more work so
restricting the Knights yeah attacking
the pawn now it could have come into G
for I guess the g5 is expected but g5 I
play g3 we trade the mine that comes in
yeah the square is so juicy for the
Knights yes this makes it to YouTube
YouTube people can say hi to scribble in
the comments you've uh you've made your
mark in history
yeah blocks in big trouble because these
squares are so weak rook G to some idea
the night really wants to come to f5
Oh people saying hi to YouTube YouTube
can say hi back in the future
oh I'm not in first anymore some people
pass me what happened was a diamond cut
or diamond cut still on a streak
good job to the diamond and Bishop see
it's a good move I before me
attack the knight I'm trying to make the
knight move away
okay unleashing the file getting ready
for this
I'm just trying to build a pressure like
these pieces can only defend so much
King g7 really like to remove my pawn
9f5 I think what I'll do is this rooks
not doing anything I'll put it on F -
maybe this rook will have some x-ray
vision there might be some H four
possibilities there's some night c4 idea
but knife yeah knife f5 has finally come
and the H file
yeah I was trying to use a the F file
and then the G file but now it's
actually the H file which is open and
free to use this Knight has no legal
moves
I'll work g7 my knight is not worth the
rook the knight still like just trapped
a triple battery if I'm planning to take
the night I'm probably threatening this
Wow plaques pieces with the blacks
pieces that's so fun
where's my wind just play a simple move
come on just a simple move well I lost a
pawn but now like everything's trapped
for for a flag even the Knights the
night has no moves I'm threatening me as
a funny game yeah you to people I mean
at this face sudden I think I might just
want to put this whole tournament on
YouTube but we'll see if I don't you
people hope you enjoyed that playing
Pembina I'll play another afore ye e six
I'll play a two Knights attack I still
owe you tuba what does this move f5
gonna say I still owe you tuba a two
Knights attack video 5 hmm I think I can
just take either way
hi d4 and this this square is very weak
Finn sack thanks for subbing and G
Sansan chezj also thanks for subbing
appreciate the the new and returning
subs play this move yeah this is like
very nice positional game so far I like
the Queen on each three because they
can't really be attacked
it applies constant pressure I mean 92
ideas c3 and f3
one hectare per bit hahaha just kidding
hi oh hi - dirt boy soft
thanks for the that's it's 100 bits oh
and thanks for leaving out the 100 pots
play each five I could also preserve my
mission Oh actually there's a small trap
it takes I can take with Queen cuz I
might just win a piece might has to move
back you want to play in that a for at
the right points
I think I'll play each five firsts I'm
trying to eventually check means like
each 5 9 F for Queen g5 okay we're gonna
have a end game late middle game not
sure what stage of game this is once the
Queen's get traded it kind of feels like
an end game but this is pleasant cuz I
have a passed pawn
it'll be supported by a rook at least
Wow
94 did not see that coming it's a
playable move
we'll just take and play g3 but the
point is I lose back a piece so I'm
holding on to my Knights the Knights are
precious I'll play this move the
Bishop's going to find the square
I bumped us on here
hmm no g5s coming
oh if g5 I have a ever nice idea to play
this in this except I can't play this
right away because there's a pin let's
start with this yeah once the night
comes to f6 it's me
very very nice play it now I think the
King doesn't have anywhere great to go
if you're here I take with check looking
a chains yeah Brooke each one's coming
Brooke h2 is coming also this is coming
yeah blocks just losing oh that's a
tricky move maybe it locks not losing
okay King D - the point is to get out of
the pin if this I can just take it if
this I pin I think the bishops just
trapped
yeah the bishops just trapped I can just
take because it rooks not defended well
I can't take back then I defend 0
I'll bring my knight back at 6 triangle
which instructs I'm eating that this is
kind of risky because I'm allowing black
to promotes by this better just be
winning allowing black to promote 86
idea rook f7 mates it's actually kind of
a nice finish yeah it takes takes it
doesn't make a difference that was nice
Kiyomi yeah you're kind of late but
you're actually like halfway through the
tournament's also back to tournaments
okay I'm in second place
oh no you're um you're only like 37 in
the slates so I'm staying clean I have
five wins trying to catch up to Rosario
90 it is important like for these types
of tournaments to win games efficiently
and not have everything go the full
distance any plans for a varied stream
not entirely but I mean let me know what
variants you want me to stream play nine
oh six I'm gonna mix it up in the play
and limbs Oh cuz why not yeah Bishop d2
is not the most active move it blocks a
queen so d4 is a bit more tender can I
win anything
b5 let's try b5 it's already getting
kind of spicy take take again there's no
e4 cuz I can just take I think I'm
starting to take here now I want to play
d5 yeah I'm complaining with this
opening atomic and crazy house okay I'll
keep that in mind let's see with Queen
not sure what this accomplishes I mean
there's Queen h6 I'm Biju's attacks
okay so let's castle oh these pawns are
so majestic I'll play Knight c6 rookie
aids just keep applying pressure
ooh opponent did not identify my threats
everything crumbles now the Queen's hits
queen c3 ideas the rooks undefended and
aligned with my queen king is a a
sitting duck
yeah 92 I I can take on de to also take
on e3 this actually looks kind of more
fun because 94 wow everything stuck for
a white guy reminds me of a previous
game I've see three year I could take
nine of three there's so many ways to
win in 3 c3 is probably the most
gruesome
yeah just so many different directions
also officially 6 is now a threat I got
three mates
Wow one of mates oh that's so nice
White's pieces on the back ring okay
doctor turn it okay
I've reclaimed my my spots of glory I
have to just keep this spot for the next
hour and 20 minutes playing chooce I'll
play you for again before has been
serving me well I'll try another two
nights attack okay we have a what is
this run steam sort of something what to
play here Queenie - makes sense
ah so black wants to take and then the
other night on that six which I might
have to allow wondering if there's any
any alternatives I actually see
something crazy involves sacking a queen
I was just looking at this this and then
this do I dare sack my queen it's not
called for I don't know if I can stop
myself little cuz I sack a queen and a
knight I can't stop myself
I'm sake I'm sacking all my pieces oh it
doesn't oh it doesn't work it doesn't
work oh that was so bad I forgot I
forgot ninety five spot possible I just
lost a queen and a knight for nothing
that's so bad now I have to justify my
terrible decisions
that was really bad at least the Kings
on e6 maybe there's some there's some
hope I have about 500 rating points
above my opponents I have to avoid
trades let's play g3 stopping anything
from coming to f4
I'm preventing the king from running
away this way of course the King runs
away the other way that's put the rook
in this is so bad oh it should you gonna
be one always play king b1 and save my
king
don't attack me I'm down so much
material I could I could play b3
actually b3 so risky I'll play rook c1
some idea of c4 top ones playing quickly
and strongly undeveloped time mmm I've
three such a sad move each threes a move
so I'll do this stuff Bishop c1 f1 is
playing really quickly but it's
justified coming down so much material
mmm
also many regrets this might be a move
actually it's a nifty move the pawns
gonna save the king even further the
scheme is so safe it's protected by so
mental things can redevelop the Knights
I could undeveloped my mission I did
this ship g2 also over defending my pawn
so I can redevelop later
yeah c4 is just terrifying around yeah
b4 is terrifying thinking about legacy
for what else to do
I should have played 83 actually it's
not a great move to allow I guess I have
to take I grew up d1 okay let's play
this move preventing Bishop f5 which
could have been played earlier you're
really just hoping for a miracle
I don't know what to play running low on
time too
don't need me please don't need me
okay redeveloping my Knights
trying to keep things complicated - I
feel like that's one hope they'll just
put the rock random ch5 doing anything
to avoid trades 1.95
this is so bad I don't know why suck my
queen like that it's getting late
people can tear me apart in the future
YouTube comments what does 91 91 I mean
I really want to play Bishop d2 let's do
it made this bow to stick with a rook no
I can't do that to do this taking a
bishop
hmm
it's really nasty that's a really good
move Oh what to do
oh dear it's trying so hard to survive -
it's not it's not gonna end well but I
do have a few cattle training a fork I
always have to look on the bright side
of things what a what a bad decision
what to do wait what about durians and
miss something in the chat there's some
discussion Nigerians okay so I didn't
this month I'm in the second cuz regrets
III didn't see 95 I was I was
calculating like all these King move
lines I got too excited okay let's play
a dragon there's some discussion about
dragon earlier I'll play accelerated oh
thanks so much
compact buffalo ah d5 yeah I could never
so right saying I could never use too
much good luck okay so this looks
reasonable rook e8 attacking the pawn
there's Knight f4 potential it's a nice
kind of dragon position you play e5
preparing that of for hitting the bishop
preparing Queen g5 threatening to win
the bishop and the Queen
I will say it's really nice having a
queen on the board it's so much more
potential it's also nice not being down
material leave this move what to play
okay this is kind of a tricky move also
white I think White's in trouble here
because if take stakes I win the bishop
it takes I um I win the Queen yeah okay
now now I get to see how it feels like
to be up a green all the minor pieces
are hanging mmm maybe this move this is
a tricky move like counter-attack the
bishop if white takes the knight I take
back and hitting the rook also the Queen
is aggressively placed I forgot about
that move okay everything's still
hanging like even I'm threatened
threatening my g3 are threatening this
sagnik a royai asking how did he miss at
even if you saw I don't know what he was
supposed to do let's take this
I can go back to that pointed show
hoping for Ritchie one it's already made
here feels close to me
oh there's no night g3 actually I'll
play on only this month
oh there's there's a cool idea hoping
for this also Condor thanks for subbing
and the ship is kind of annoying
let's keep attacking it I'm just trying
to chase the bishop off this diagonal
I think I'm succeeding the bishop I'm
controlling all these squares now if
rook d1 o there's g3 but now I can
counter-attack
I was gonna say if rook t1 I have this
move o the counter counter attack this
preparing for meets the bishop still
attacked at Bishop a3 I just play Roxy -
oh why not yeah I should have taken the
bishop because I had Queen f1 mates I
forgot about that
but okay I'll get out of the pen and
then mates coming yeah it's so focused
on like bringing the rook into play okay
works out and ends so I'm chasing I
might have to start buzzer King more
it's chase first an hour and six minutes
it's still not even halfway through the
tournament much coffee have I had
there's no caffeine in this cheese so
I'm getting more tired as we speak as I
speak what's happening on the counter
what you mean by counter like the
countertop or the timer the one who
counts oh that's okay let's play this mu
I played this opponent many times before
we're gonna have I'm gonna have a
Halloween happy Halloween let's just
invite back I mean don't try this at
home kids
I just want to meet there should be
threes a move I can take and take on b2
there's Queen g3 as well yeah I don't
know how white defends the night I mean
I could take but then I take and chop
the rook
I guess there's King f2 if I can play d4
problem with d4 isn't it takes e4 so
let's just move that I can I'll take on
me - hmm
am I not and then one more check can't
hurt but now once this is kind of risky
but the Queen's tied down to the rook it
takes I might just Castle first you want
to take back with Rooker Bishop
in Leyte four so I'm down the piece I'm
sacking another piece it's a spirit of
Halloween Bishop g4 on the horizon if
this move this is really risky I don't
think this is paying off but it might I
don't know jack King was here I have
this move there's that move well I can
take okay so I'm trading Queens I'm
still down a piece I got some pawns for
it I got an open that file let's start
with g6 I guess II five maybe uh maybe
be 65 or be 65 I want to be like as
restrictive as possible
wow that's check take a look on I dare
you Wow white accepted my dare and now
is about to get mated but how knight c6
King e6 it's so weird I don't want to
let the King slip away but okay like 96
there's also just Kings he's Savin quiet
move he bring that came to c6 and me
there's also the concept of dirty
flagman Knight f5 it's desperate move
I'm looking for me I should just look to
flag my opponent or meets there's a mate
okay can you see six coming
Wow okay threatening me than one again
threatening me than one okay
so weird game Halloween paid off let's
go it's still in second place so also
znation I don't know if I said hi to you
welcomes you nation maybe you've been
here for a while we have some like
original like some of the longest time
viewers like z nation Kiyomi I've been
watching the stream for at least the
last two years I think okay I playing
another two nights attack we'll see what
this player does so far I've run into
take and f5 at Lisa's tournaments
[Music]
opponents perplexed not used to seeing
so many nights okay have the main line
maybe yeah the difference between this
and the advanced French is that with
this line whites happy to trade off the
center pawns advance French usually like
place e3 and holds on to the pawns Oh
double comic yeah that will come welcome
back it's another knee
twitch has this new feature where you
can see how many messages people have
sent in the chat curious who wins Wow
yeah Kiyomi wins out of number of
messages I have been sent znation a
close second I don't know if people in
the chat can see I think only I can see
anyway okay we have we have one of the
main lines h6 is kind of suspicious but
sometimes it's played to prevent the
Greek gift of casting I could have taken
a on each seven wait you you barely talk
in chat you've sense can I reveal the
number I'll reveal a number you sent
over 900 messages but over the span of
two years so I'm barely talking can Anna
I don't want to give up my bishop and
call I'll just go back and then a3 yeah
so a3 Bishop d3 Oh Thomas Thomas beats
everyone Thomas has sent over 999
messages I think it stops counting once
you surpass a thousand a shout-out to
Thomas
hmm f6 is interesting
I wanted to play Queenie too
I'm also attempted to sack I don't know
why I've always tempted to sack
let's take I could play Queenie to take
with the bishop I could also just take
in Bishop g3 let's do that play this
move
so black has to Sanger cons I have zero
Center phones also bicycle how's it
going you weeks back in the states a
wifey please go very nice that's nice to
hear
enjoy your time I hope I hope life is
good I hope life is good I take yeah
let's yeah I'm being passive blacks
playing pretty well so far but taking a
lot of time I have a secret threat
though Bishop e7 it looks purely passive
but it's actually it is attacking
something the threat it was this I think
I can do this maybe maybe not but maybe
no probably not
the problem is after it takes lock can
take here and I take the pawn takes
takes it was Queen e6 blocking the check
and counter check
so I think I'll just trade everything
like we need to we'll trade here and
I'll be slightly worse I don't think
it's too bad though this Bishop is solid
it's hard for a block to advance without
giving me stuff shifty for a while it's
just taken castle I'm okay to play this
position I want to play rook d1 she had
the good thing about this situation with
the pawns as I have the two half open
files so the pawns are kind of sitting
ducks always play King me one I try need
to take probably not but can I take if I
take take take and the King moves I take
here look here
that's probably no good yeah so but I
can never move this pawn without losing
this pawn and the goal is to just
started tagging six maybe Bishop g4
coming three pawns for the piece yeah
but like when you have three pawns
against the player having two bishops it
usually doesn't end well
it's a play I can check
have sex
okay just applying pressure there's some
idea of no burka for the King moves back
maybe I'll play f4 like we have a
situation where we both have
LightSquared bishop and in this case you
want your pawns and darks where's [ __ ]
cutting all the pawns on light squares I
see three
oh I'm giving luck some opportunity you
think I'll take and play g3 if I could
have taken first and then rook c8 you
always played Bishop f1 the other idea
is to target g6 okay I'll find it sir in
the Chopin after focus first
there's Bishop eh
I'm still better for whites but box kind
of holding on no no John this is not
easy to play this with so little time
okay
finally one upon wanna win another pawn
ooh
tricky not so tricky okay
good game I'm still in second but only
by one points first place lost the
streak I got my streak let's go also
welcome oh Scriv e says good morning
from Alberta
what's Groovy's been here for a long
time also shout outs it's all the people
from Alberta and elsewhere 20:56 yeah
that's all buzzer I'll play aggressively
blunder let's play just play a Grand
Prix mmm yeah I'm gonna try and keep up
a string and try and play quickly Tim if
we're preventing b5 all these moves are
are very typical Grand Prix moves
I just want to attack I might end up
gambling this pawn
this looks fun let's hold on to the pond
for a little bit
there's some idea of it should be 191
then c3 and then this and then this and
the bishop comes to life that could take
a while but it's possible I'll be
aggressive
that's my goal oh I can't do that
hmm oh do I'll do this move if takes I I
just Sackler Brooke I think
well it's a raid a it's are we supposed
to thanks the weights I have to focus if
you're just joining I got wrapped up in
playing this tournaments shoutouts so
the wizard are we supposed to yeah I was
watching I was actually lurking earlier
I was watching some of those those blitz
games hope you had a good stream oh
let's play this move well yeah if you're
just joining I have 30 points in second
place neither has 31 I've been chasing
this person for a while and this might
be the game okay let's take with Knight
this Bishop is such a such a dud okay
let's do this
soon to be a dude once the diagonal
opens up okay no I can't play that like
g4 lead school
thanks for the bits 299 I I can't take
what to do here g4 doesn't quite work
I actually don't know what to do I'm in
trouble and I'm down a lot of time I
think I'll just sack because why not
because meets GU and then like my h3 sad
move but that night was annoying me in
51 seconds
f1 is considering taking the night or
just flustered that I'm I'm sake
material
it ones very flustered trying to figure
out my hidden idea
I probably would move quickly if it was
known my hidden ideas and I teach three
yeah maybe I'll have to mix in a Smith
Mora at some point smooth
[Music]
okay so there's there's some potential
because this this Bishop is is having a
lot of potential sort of this d4 could
ruin all my happiness but then Bishop a2
actually so it's not that bad
and yeah opponents taking a lot of time
d4 bishop a - now e6 is of targets find
IG one idea of Knight f3 and I just want
to control ePHI oh I lost a queen no oh
that's so bad I come down on time why
did I not see I guess I wasn't expecting
the Queen's I come to h4 that's really
bad it's another like just unnecessary
queen blunder that wasn't even a
sacrifice test cabbage is haunting me
this is so sad I'm trying to know don't
know what I'm trying to do you win a
pawn
I can't move that I'm completely stuck
this is probably payback for all the
opponents I previously tortured I mean
I'm not gonna give up just yet
no this mission never came to life to do
85 no tricks
oh that's so disappointing
if I didn't lose the Queen if only but
that's I guess the nature of karma maybe
there's still hope I mean the first
place is now first place has been
renamed stirring off almost as high
rated than or almost as high rated as me
one point behind okay I need to I need
some dessert the rest of the games I
guess this could make or break oh I'm
playing stirring off by berserk probably
not
there's still enough time play dragon
thanks for the condolence bits yeah we
have a whatever this is
ROTC bind might see to might see to I
think a5 a4 include d6 and Queen e5
should be six I was looking at some
similar position earlier I was doing Q&A
earlier answering questions about the
dragon we saw we saw some game where
black was doing this stuff play Knight
c5 we believe in you marry Oh
Thank You Sonya I'll try and believe in
me too oh the queen was attacked I keep
forgetting my Queens attacks like
various places I think I should be seven
and a six it's a little bit unpleasant
what to do here king of AIDS just trying
to hold on
I can't plate you sixes it's too
beginning maybe Brooke a six now if I
play a six there's no night p6 there's
my f6 each six I'll go for this or no no
no no no I meant to play e6 first but I
guess that's fine now I play you six
I played the like the second or third
move in the variation before the first
move Emily's opening repertoire could
not be more different than mine I'd
losing material here take stakes
who might be in trouble
I'm in a lot of trouble actually it was
a good move but it's still kind of weird
night the night has to find a square and
now and despites along with both rooks
we he owe me heat so London
I might have to consider unknotting but
that's ok I understand a lot of people
hate various things but they're ready I
mean the ready is just two moves away
from transposing to a London okay I
should stay more focused there's a lot
riding on this game
well this there's a whole cluster of
minor pieces Amira pieces are just like
kind of attracted to one another I guess
oh wow okay I I mean I don't really have
any other choice you don't hurt me okay
so I'm down I'm down two pawns not sure
what to do you could try it with a pawn
back
okay let's try night before some idea of
this my dear
probably not taking me - yeah this was
this was my worst piece board so get rid
of it now I could take a to take a - an
e5 coming trying to make like some
progress on the licking side around the
Queen sign I want to win B - maybe some
idea of maybe three
good sack let's not say all pieces on
the queenside now hmm interesting play
this move so now this pawn is probably
just a goner I have six or if defense
Wow so I'm winning both mom's back
there's Bishop c4 injure meso I don't
think it matters too much my knight
controls a one so there's no Rock a one
let's take Knights vs. bishop
the knight is just chilling oh my pawns
weak
okay Roxy two takes d3 play g5 first
play g5 first the Bishop g2 I have rook
c2 a bit up here I haven't seen one
surprisingly now the promised king
there's a crazy line let's start with
this Guinea - I'm looking at this okay
one I may have just like messed up
completely I think I just messed
everything up
I can't please no I can't play that move
from g4 maybe try g4 to try this idea
this is not looking good
I have the time - okay let's move back
why didn't I see three at some points
now's the time it's a tricky move
because it's forking if pawn takes
Bishop takes like when the bishop I also
prevent rook B - I'm down two minutes
have a feeling white might not some not
take Zack the exchange to get ready for
the time scramble ooh
it's unexpected
hmm see - I don't see it try this I just
didn't see the win okay no that doesn't
work
let's bring the king in ooh this doesn't
work either
I'm trying them
okay yes let's go well the game oh
that's what it takes to take down first
place
oh okay ooh okay I'll play d5 Oh noose
well things bicycle back yeah I was down
a minute I was down material but somehow
I came back but I'm still still trying
to work my way towards first place also
this is a really dubious opening another
opening not to be tried at home but okay
I have some in some developments down
the pawn that's to 128 a.m. tournament
ends and just over a half hour
okay got some time
they have the chance I want a castle
here's my my next several moves castling
rook e8 h 6 Queenie 7 I have to take
with Knights if Queen e2 I Castle tricky
move what time of day do you feel like
you play your best chess probably not at
this time but I'm having a decent
results I've got some dirty games okay
rook e8 coming do you have any other job
than just streaming chess YouTube
I'm putting streams on YouTube actually
it's turned into more of a job recently
let's take a free pawn also I'll be I'll
be doing reporting and social media for
st. Louis chess club during the upcoming
events starting tomorrow actually
actually later today is opening ceremony
play this move let's just move back I'll
try and manage my time to here Brooke
Yeates let's play rook e8 here I play
this move
and I could take with the Queen it's
funny
everything looks hanging but nothing's
really hanging the Siam
I checked the road the Knights always
pumped I'll play Bishop d3 this is
looking very good right now as I was
getting ready to play this forgetting my
bishop is necessary to pin the lights
ooh
it's a tricky move I can take the
Knights and now like why can't take
either bishop this bishops curing the
Queen yeah I'll just be up at least a
rook in the end
so a win in this game will make me like
right behind first place I think I could
take the this is nice
I'm just simplifying basically it takes
I have this move
ooh I plundered yeah I can't really wow
I guess I guess the best move is just to
take here
ooh that was nice I think my opponent
remove this okay so this is completely
winning now it could have been more
difficult to win yeah so it's just a
matter of winning efficiently let's do
let's do this move on this move okay so
the goal is to meet without promoting
okay never mind
my mother promotes get back to
tournaments let's go 35 points to people
with 36 right above me but neither of
them have streaks this could be very
important
next game bicycle thanks for the bits ok
trying my best here yeah I kind of
forgot to address chats there's some
discussion about the ready and who is a
sky and it was up there was a super
super spy and tried us ok mmm
let's play this move thief d6 so
slightly past the opening yeah I'm happy
with this next several moves are very
natural for lights I think I had this
earlier in the tournament to play play
f3 like king each one there's it b3
Queen c2 a lot of kind of slow improving
moves
okay Knights like C - maybe no need G
now that v was a move I should have
considered
a-and I say special-ops gifting subs
thanks so much
Leon Dyke and dog emits appreciate that
okay I have to remember that I desserts
because I don't want to get too long
time playing a decently hiring the
player okay the position is still kind
of playing itself play Bishop f1 because
always played this [ __ ] off on some nice
x-ray vision super spy thanks for the
bits the goal is to put them on
indieformer
d4 and then maybe i-5 yeah now if takes
takes a this should be comes pins Knight
has to move away the queen is now lost
okay it's nice when the opponent hangs
our Queen adjacent double pawns the game
continues
if Brooke takes her knight takes Bishop
c4 if this takes I have Queen c7
she thinking about just when I have six
in her but it's just taken going for the
kill
okay does that did that do anything for
me that did something for me okay at 40
points it's still chasing leader who's
also berserk Inge and who just started
another game
oh thanks bicycle I'm gonna have to try
and keep it up I have to stay awake
there's only 22 minutes left it's not
much time for more games I'm really
rooting for this player and this if
white wins a scheme then yeah they keep
the lead let's play e4
yeah there's irking all the way let's
play b3 French I have 64 yeah it's not
so common still it's a very nice kind of
dynamic way it's also a nice way to get
like an open position from the French a
lot of French players prefer closed
positions at the right moment I want to
play g5 gotta play g5 last move let's
play g5 and then take it secret them
like defending the pawn unleashing of
bishop if casting I'll have lots of fun
with attacking mm slightly unexpected
I'll start with this it's kind of a
patient move
I'm just being flexible I'm just seeing
what black is up to let's play this move
the Queen and the bishop control Z
squares so there's no night move to
attack my queen and I want to develop my
knight here or maybe here because that
way I'll H 5 H 5 H 6
oh there's 94 this is some idea it might
see 4 I'll just play this move so e5
what to do slowly improve okay I want to
bring my knight in it Queen here yeah
pressuring the pawn also over defending
g5 to play h5 h6 also unleashing the F
pawn they might just want to play f4
castle and open that file soaking wet
sigh welcome back or if you've been here
already
hello don't think I said hello to you
okay let's castle or no let's play let's
play this move first
yeah c5 is coming Lucy if I drop
submission
oh but 9f5 but neither five Queen f3 hmm
you know play this first just trying
trying to puncture some hole in blacks
defense
I might actually play b5 soon if I make
some sense trying to River just win this
pond if not if I'm just Queen each -
yeah we could be trading a lot I take
the bishop first takes takes let's take
first again down on time that that's
typical okay so I got rid of darks for
it if Queen takes I'll trade Queens if
pawn takes I'll play f4 probably or
Queen at for probably Queen us forward
actually if Queen takes we trade they'll
play Bishop eform
I just want to take him in the pawn
these pawns combine very well with this
Bishop which should come to life yeah
cuz now their works attacks not like
king d2 made cool thanks for Selena I
grow up I want to be like Eric Rosen
that's so nice yeah I hope I'm a
reasonable role model let's play play
this move
can I win this up to win the pawn this
should be pretty simple simple win it
takes some work start with this
Lykos to play d4 and then keep walking
the King even Ricki three balls for this
move
oh that's it's not a good move that
might be a good move actually oh that
was probably just a bad move baby six
not good
okay I'm going going into blacks
position I don't know about this but
Kings finding some activity
I'm gonna win the pond probably and
maybe one time to locks getting low
laughs for yeah so Bishop c4 I always
have rookie seven it's a good move or no
it's not a good move cuz I'm in the pond
now let's push him let's keep pushing
yeah this is uh this is a pretty simple
wind now but I still have my work cut
out for me
Keeney six and then this is me okay 45
to 46 oh but um this this guy didn't
pisser so there's a chance for me to at
least tie if I'm bezerk win the next
game bicycle thanks for the bits how
much diet or how do I have so much chest
stamina if to sleep in absolute stay fit
to work out I went to the gym Lee eats 8
to 9 p.m. yeah this is it was like I
have to dessert to fight for first oh
that's a good sign ok thanks for dessert
you know back components this is my
first in London of the tournaments and
maybe of the stream the opponent doesn't
know what to do against the London which
is great to see this move if 97-90 okay
that's a very pleasant position here I
want the Queen's would be on each three
and then push the Jeep on and then meet
hopefully this will inspire the London
haters to pick up this opening it's such
a great opening like the pieces are so
happy they're so well coordinated like
Queen Queen h3 it's basically the same
thing I can jump in and jump into each
six I could play Bishop h6 should be 697
you know f6 is coming
they go I'll play this and then I'll
move like maneuver around perhaps think
with f4 I might be inviting me five
though ooh take the rook take the role
so well then just sack the exchange for
questionable compensation let the Queen
back and maybe push the H upon this move
yeah let's just trade stuff
I don't know if attacking is the best
strategy but it looks nice against this
pawn the rook belongs in d1
there's a smooth
oh yeah Queen c2 is met with rook D -
ooh wait oh no I can't play I have three
leave this move go and then then let's
start with that three I might trade
Queens but I might just go for me I'm
not sure how
oh that move taking doesn't work just g4
ephors a movie for g5
a g5 s coming regardless I'll c4 is nice
g'bye chief I'll lead SKU yeah let's go
oh it's love HS love HS have you been
here this whole time
Wow almost as long as me let's play this
[Music]
mm okay it's kind of getting annoying I
don't have the thing Oh G five pounds
about to be distinguished or
extinguished not distinguished uh what
to do before maybe oh that doesn't work
this I want the game to be on d3 let's
attack the Jeep on I want to play off
for though before it's getting
complicated
one's about to flag though oh it's me
it's meat that's funny
okay let's go let's go in first place is
still playing I'll have time for one
more game
this could very well be the last game
ready for the staffing meets GU thanks
bicycle okay we have complete symmetry
I'll copy catch s ok deviating from
White's shenanigans yeah III think just
helps me put the bishop on them a better
square okay let's play this move and
then maybe this move yeah bleats Koo
okay d5 coming d5 threatening to win a
piece because Fork potential defy wins
ookies frames
I think d5 wins apiece opponents
threatening sneaky snack or sneaky sack
sneaky snack
wow so sneaky but I don't think it works
better not work takes takes takes
there's money for though maybe let's
start with this 94 it doesn't hurt me
don't think
oh that was the best move though I see
so I was gonna forth the bishop anyway
okay so I'm up a piece this is very good
there's seven minutes left in the
tournament let's just try and convert
this cleanly the Queen in want to play
this move get into h2 and me
also attacking before hoping for a
rookie one my own messes other threats
Wow
so let's play before just unleashing the
Queen and nineth one was expected I'll
just keep building up the position also
the G files half open so I have rookie
eights move over yeah let's move over
first lights defended and yeah I might
have for coming in let's take first and
9 F for still coming
Oh 2nd place still still within reach
and ok so I want to win the skin quickly
ideally I would like to win this game
unless somthing minutes and then have
time for one working waste pieces not
really helping defend the King like g3
might come thinking Knights ih4 so just
so I have access to f3 the more
centralized I'm trying to calculate
taking or even taking first even let
each five there's a lot of ideas this
move I honestly didn't calculate I'm
trusting intuition
because takes Queen h2 takes okay let's
take here and then I can just keep
taking stuff F Queen takes 99 I take on
G to probably just take the rook at time
is running out for the tournaments oh
yeah it's a mini mug its o know how to
like it's it's smaller than my hand
don't have a banana for scale okay let's
take I don't even know if we can call it
a mug it's more like a teacup but thanks
anyway
I want to just made on G to Bishop a
sudden opinion okay now let's sum it
should be something to learn anything
unfortunately okay thanks for that let's
take their okay the bishops are coming
to life check I'm in the Queen
even the pole if the pond stalls I still
I still get the tournament points no
please don't stall I want one more game
the Queen each to Chuck yeah Queenie
choo the King with a variety of a brand
I played the way I did to win material
okay oh installing so yes we can watch
the scheme
[Music]
it's actually a fascinating game that's
not looking good
Buddha's dollar he yeah what to do
done my job for the tournaments
and like I can't claim the victory
because opponents on the line like the
rest of the game I can pre move
basically
ooh the scheme that's still going
interesting oh it's not gonna last
okay this could be a very close finish
that's a tournament opens are closed so
I got I got my 50 Oh starina have lost
Oh Serena was on the worst side of that
Oh
so I think I won no one else can catch
me let's go let's go we don't need to to
be mad about the Staller it didn't
affect things so the light keeps falling
what a tournament thanks so much yeah I
want a trophy
i won I'll be winning like a virtual
trophy well we'll wait for the confetti
thanks so much people have a good night
thanks so much bicycles yeah enjoy enjoy
the food in the gym and the being home
Congrats
thank you Alexander's horse still have
40 seconds left of the tournament
woof HS ah maybe there's something to
starting the stream with geoguessr oh
it's a thousand dents
whoo-hoo well geoguessr was earlier I
ended the stream earlier with geoguessr
rosin let's go rats thanks so much this
stream has to go on YouTube now right
yeah I was I was talking to the future
you two people earlier thanks so much
are we supposed to hey the tournaments
the confetti so much happy confetti I
could put myself in the confetti yeah
I feel like the Spelling Bee champion
looks slightly happier okay that was
nice yeah so people watching in the
future on YouTube hope you enjoyed that
oh thanks again oh-oh-oh
Alexa didn't want to do it but yeah
before before sweet oh it's very it's
very sweet
I'm gonna sign off for the future you
two people before we have copyrighted
content that's quite action-packed well
thanks so much sagnik hey Roy
yeah future YouTube people I'm gonna try
and remember to leave timestamps in the
video description maybe the comments so
you can you can search for specific
openings or moments feel free to leave
timestamps below too and I'll see you in
the future